What's Going On guys This is rob and If
You're enjoying the content that i'm
uploading onto My Channel then feel free
to Subscribe And you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on  in this
channel so normally on wednesdays we do
a video on how to kill Superheroes but
We're actually going to Bypass that for
this week and I think we'll probably
bring it back next week but Uh The
Reason Why I want to Bypass it  this week
Is because of the fact that Of course we
do All new all different Marvel or DC
rebirth every other day It's one of the
two I just kind of alternate between
whichever One I think is more
interesting but Legion Comes out tonight
and so I wanted  to do something related
to Legion I thought about doing Legion
Quest but The issue is you can't do
Legion Quest without doing Age of
apocalypse and it'll be a while Before I
jump into all that There's a lot of
other Stories that I want  to cover
Before I go back and remaster that whole
thing Uh because That's a huge story but
with regards To the whole Uh the whole
idea of ​​Age of x this was a really cool
concept Now what this means for the
x-men in the Marvel Universe  We actually
get to at the end of that at the end of
this video Which is kind of weird
because i us get into the exposition
before we start the video We're actually
going to pick up with What this means at
the end of the video  but the cool thing
about Age of X and We're actually going
to leave a little bit out here cu I
think it makes it better if we do with
Age of x What we do is We just picked up
on day 1000 and this is cool  because
We're kind of given like this This
explanation by rogue Right you know rog
is like this is day 1000 We're a000 Days
into this Conflict and What We find out
is that you know by way of her
exposition and things that are going  on
that There's essentially This is like the
last haven for mutants in the world that
some massive War some massive has Broken
out and the result is that magneto
grabbed What was left of the of the
mutant community and just took them to
this one location Which is  called
fortress X and every single day There is
a Nonstop or not really a Nonstop but
every single day There is an ons of
humanity and An attempt to Attack Uh
Attack What's left of the mutant
population in order to take them out now
the cool thing about  this is that We get
this disembodied Voice from a person
known only as x and x is kind of like
this all- encompassing thing right it's
like jarvis from the Marvel cinematic
Universe right I mean like Tony just
talks to jarvis jarvis responds It's the
same way  here with this story in the
Sense that x allows the Uh various
mutants that Are Here in this Conflict
to basically organized fronts to decide
you know who needs to go and Where x
monitors vital signs of those
individuals Who are currently fighting
It's kind of like this  omnipresent being
or concept of some sort that
communicates with them but the cool
thing is that Of course this group as We
see him is kind of a mishmash of
different things It's a mishmash of the
x-men Legacy team and It's a mishmash Of
New mutants  Keep in mind new mutants was
originally designed to be The sort of
reimagining of the original x-men in the
Sense that Where Chris clm one of the
x-men was wildly popular you know Night
crawler colossus w r so on and so forth
Marvel wanted to  bring back the original
premise of the x-men but do so in a way
that could tap into Young readers so We
got like Daniel moonstar and we got a
lot of these younger mutants that xav
was basically Training as a new team for
the purpose of  carrying on the x-men
mantle After The original x-men had
grown Up and basically moved on and so
because of this It's really kind of cool
to see this Conflict play out but things
end Quick Fast and in a hurry I mean
It's not a  huge deal but There are some
notable differences in terms of
characters that We're
especially with cyclops and this is where we
start to get a lot of this exposition a
lot of this backstory in the Sense that
What we learned was familiar that at some Point
along the Line mutants began emerging in
a much different way that were used to change
what did basically happen Here
is that cyclops powers emerged in a
movie theater you know and people were
killed because of that as opposed to his
powers just kind of emerging arbitrarily
in  a class I think it was or something
along those Lines Uh Je gray's powers of
telepathy and telekinesis didn't emerge
by way of her basic hearing voices
instead they emerged by way of the
Phoenix force in albany New York and it
was kind of like the  stanford
connecticut initiating Civil War kind of
situation in the Sense that jean Gray
you know emerging as the Phoenix force
cost the lives of Some 600,000 people
and in response it was this Days of
Future pas es situation the difference
Here is that Where Days of Future pas
saw like the reformation of the
sentinel program instead What we have
here in Age of x are called exs and exs
are basically just kind of like enhan
humans so on and so forth but the
difference is that mutants were basic
rounded Up and a lot of  they Were thrown
In alcatraz The issue is that When they
were thrown in alcatraz cyclops because
he had optic beams was Used by humanity
to basically execute mutants He would
they would literally take his powers and
they would use them to kill mutants that
were considered to be  killed and so because
of this This is one of the reasons Why
magneto grabbed whatever he could grab
whatever Heroes were left and brought
them over to this place fortress x Now
what we also Have Is this barrier This
being created this constantly being
restored by the combined  efforts of
Legion byoc and a handful of others they
use their pic ability to basically put
up this wall that humanity constantly
has to try to take out all the time and
That's basically How they try to keep
themselves safe you know they basically
create this force wall  the humanity has
to fight through and then by the time
they get done with all that they're met
with like waves of you know a handful of
Xmen and new mutants now the other half
of this is We have more mtag now more
mtag being Here  is kind of cool because
remember She's like the foremost
geneticist when it Comes to mutant so If
There was any kind of mutant scientist
that you would want on your side It
would be her something else to Point out
Here is that below this below this whole
facility  you know within fortress x
itself is wolver the difference Here is
that during this whole Conflict during
this whole birth of mutants Uh the Death
of 600,000 humans the idea that humanity
was fighting against them wolver Rain
was used to basically create a cure and
it was Used  on wolv Rain himself and so
because of that Logan basically does not
seem to have a healing Factor and even
he says that He says look because of the
fact that my healing Factor is gone I'm
basically dying of adamantium poisoning
and we know That's the  case right like
We Know That's the case with Wolverine
like adamantium basically you know the
reason Why adamantium bonding never seemed
to work with anyone before wol Rain was
because they didn't have a healing
factor and It would essentially just
Shut their bodies down their bodies
would die of adamantium poisoning if
they didn't die Through The the bonding
process itself with wolver not having a
healing factor He's essentially just
dying It's poisoning his body not only
that you know He's basically talks to Uh
talks to one of the characters here and
says look If I pop My claws I'm going to
die like I'm basically just going to
bleed out and so it's basically wolver
being deed you know He has no more Real
abilities There's really nothing He can
do and so what happens is that  We
basically have rogue here rogue
basically plays the role of someone
called Legacy now the reason Why She
plays the role of Legacy Is because
She's not really a field Medic She
basically reads people their last rights
remember rogue has the ability to absorb
people's consciousness whenever It  is
that they die and so what happens is
during these conflicts whenever someone
dies rogue goes out to Where they're at
and in their Final Moments She reads
them their Final rights and then She
touches them and absorbs their
personality so they basically live on
through  her now rogue doesn't really do
this for the purpose of using their
powers rogue is just kind of like you
know a standin for priest or something
along those lines the kicker to All This
is that When rogue goes back out to the
Battlefield you know  and begins kind of
looking around and begins really you
know kind of dealing with the situation
being What It Is after She had absorbed
the memories of a girl named tempo who
had died She sees someone who basically
stumbles in from outside the wall and
when this person  Falls they basically
Face through a solid object and that
tells us This is Kitty Pride and so the
question is Where did Kitty Pride come
from like How does she get here well Of
course you know magneto immediately
responds by Sting a full contingency out
to capture Kitty  Pride and this is when
we learn that she was Someone That had
been held prisoner within fortress x by
magneto himself and Somewhere along the
Line She had been able to Engineer and
Escape had gone outside the wall and
when She came back with the camera rogue
Of  course hides it from everybody goes
to sip through the pictures and is
astonished by What she sees and so what
we do here is We pick up with magneto
When He takes the body of Kitty Pride
back to you know the prison cells
basically the Holding cells  and within
these Holding cells in addition to Kitty
Pride is Charles xavier Emma frost the
step kos now for those of you guys Who
don't know the stepford kos are actually
a really cool concept they're basically
clones of Emma frost but the difference
between  Emma And The stepford kak is
that Emma is a wildly powerful telepath
She's more powerful than charles xavier
and is Omega level in terms of her
capabilities meaning She's one of the
most powerful mutants in existence the
steff kakos actually share a hive mind
each of them has  telepathy and they're
powerful in their own right but sharing
their hive mind they're even more
powerful It's one of those things Where
it's like they're greater than the sum
of their parts you know when they're
working When they're  working Together is
a cohesive mind but It's basically you
know this idea being left to us that
Charles xavier is here but we don't know
why we don't know why He's here we don't
know why He's sedated we don't know  why
Emma frost and the stord kakos are
sedated we don't really know What's
going on in terms of Why these guys are
even being are even being held prisoners
now from here we pick up with a guy by
the name of Madison Jeff now Madison
Jeff  is actually a Pretty cool character
for those of you guys Who ever watch
like x-men the animated series Madison
Jeff is a lot like forge the difference
is that his powers Go so much further
Where forge just has the ability the
mutant ability to just know  how like
mechanical systems work Uh Madison Jeff
can do the same thing but He can
basically possess inorganic obs
basically He can manipulate machines To
basically Do Anything he wants to He's
essentially a living computer but
because of this Uh What He's been doing
throughout his entire time  here in
fortress x is He's basically been
monitoring the stars now for Why He's
doing this we don't know all we know is
that He's just doing this because it
seems to interest him or something along
those Lines but What happens is rogue
basically goes to  him for the purpose of
trying to be able to use ability or At
least copy his abilities so that she can
go and speak to Kitty Pride because
remember Kitty Pride within this prison
of for x is basically held under the
control Of A Of A Robot named  danger but
because of the fact that Madison
jeffries can speak and possess Robots
using his powers rogue could go into
this prison and she can basically or At
least it seems like she'd be able to
override control of these Robots
override the computer systems by
speaking  directly to them something else
also notice Here is that we pick up with
cyclops now Of course cyclops Talking To
The Woman in his life It's kind of a
crazy situation because with the two of
them being Together as They are It's
very different from you know like  you
know cyclops and Emma frost or something
like that as we come to expect but What
He does is he begins recalling his whole
experience on the Battlefield you know
to a Battle that was actually Three Days
prior to this and he talks about how
There was a  massive assault you know he
was able to Hold off forces you know
Pretty decently but Then He came across
Somebody Who Uh who you know basically
had been killed in the middle of an
assault now this person did not seem to
be important by any stretch of the
imagination they didn't seem to be
relevant in any Real form or fashion
instead you know what happened cyclops
just grabbed their Dog tags and it Simply
said Jackson 45th infantry 2776 now the
reason Why is cyclops does this just
kind of keep track Of The people  who
have died to keep track of the Of The
people who have been injured here but
one of the other reasons why he grabbed
This Is because as He's telling this
Woman he had this dog tag before that
this dog tag belonged to someone else
and so it  seems like There's two of
these people who died and the question
that cyclops has is why why is it
basically two of these people are they
being recycled Is there something going
on like it's basically you know the same
person attacking Over And Over Again
almost as  If they're being replicated or
the situation repeating itself time and
time Again And so because of this What
happens is We pick up with rogue once
She's actually able to get into the
prison of Kitty Pride and the first
question She asks is What was going  on
with this camera What is the deal with
this Why do you have this camera and
What does it mean that everything on it
is basically blank and Kitty Pride says
well then you know let me out And I'll
show you everything that I know i  'll
tell you what it is that I Found out
there the problem is in the middle of
all this these Robots Of course these
guards Begin to Attack and of course you
know rogue basically tries to use the
powers of Madison jeffries to override
the programming of  these of these Robots
but It doesn't work now Why It doesn't
work we don't know but We could
basically assume here that with these
Robots being designed for the purpose of
you know both guarding mutant prisoners
as well as keeping mutants within
fortress x safe that they're probably
immune to the powers of mutants Who are
here and so because of this r you know
basically You know touches Kitty Pride
takes some of her abilities phasing
through a wall and then come across
Charles xavier now Of course doing  this
is the most logical situation that We
could possibly imagine rogue touches
charles xavier and when She does she
begins to basically see Everything
That's going on in This immediate
vicinity magneto spending Time kind of
looking out of the Battlefield looking
out at things that are going on  You know
you have cyclops you have wolver Who's
cutting himself to see whether or not
his healing Factor ever going to come
back is people who are just
sitting basically here watching the events unfold
or just whatever It is they happen to be
doing at this particular time  not only
that There's also a psychic backlash to
every there but magneto seems to be The
Only One Who's aware of the fact that
This is done because of rogue now how it
is he knows It's her we don't know
because remember in this whole situation
we don't know How far back the whole
relationship between magneto and Charles
xavier goes all we know is that
magneto's here xavier here and That's
really about it now Of course you know
rogue is basically forced to make her
escape to just kind of bail out  as best
She can and run for the Hills but
because of the fact that she had gone
into the prison against the wishes of
magneto and because of the fact that she
had spoken directly with Kitty Pride and
no one knows What's Going On with her
She seems  to be An Enemy of the group
She's branded that way by magneto and
magneto goes to Daniel moonstar and says
you and your cater your task is to find
rogue and to bring Her back in here to
basically you know take her as a
prisoner She's now An  Enemy of the Uh of
the of fortress x She's An Enemy of What
stands or At least What's left of the
x-men here now at this Point We pick up
with wolver this is actually kind of
cool here because wol kind of like this
guy that  doesn't really have an
allegiance to anyone I mean He's really
just like the barke you know he He's the
guy Who's just there He's not on the
side of magneto He's not on the side of
rogue He's just kind of keeping people
safe or it just  seems to be the middle
Man Someone That people can f in but
then We find out that magneto does have
allegiances to a degree When rogue shows
Up And rogue you know is is is basically
kind of panicking Trying to understand
What's Going On Trying to figure out
What happened When She read the mind of
everybody as well as this idea that
magneto goes out and says I'm going to
go find rogue Myself as well as bringing
you know a handful Of You guys With Me
Now Of course switching back to rogue
and  wol Rain the cool thing is that you
know wol r's like What In the heck is
going on What are you doing here and
rogue says things just Don't Make Sense
things just don't quite add up There are
questions here that No one's ever
bothered to ask but once we started ask
asking those questions We find out
there's no answers something is not
right here and so what happens is before
the two of them are able to get Too Far
into their Conversation We're met with
the arrival of Daniel  moonstar and her
cater Of course basically the new
mutants in this particular story but Of
course you know once they get in they
Begin you know asking questions you know
Hey like What's Going On You know where
is rogue you know is she here and it's
really kind  of cool because they try to
do a little bit of Uh of intimidation
on Wolf r you know to basically say Hey
look If you're Housing her We're going
to consider you AN Enemy Of fortress A
but wolver Rain doesn't care  I mean He's
like do whatever Man like I mean I'm the
barkeep you know What's the worst You
can possibly do to me you can't do
anything to me that hasn't been done
already This is one of the other things
that we  learn is that the reason Why
wolver doesn't really Fight Is because
of his adamantium poisoning If he exerts
any Real measure of excitement If he you
know allows his metabolism to get too
out of control the poisoning will
literally go into hyperdrive and he'll
die extremely fast he won't die
instantaneously but his Death will be
sped up extremely Fast and so because
that we pick up with Daniel moonstar
cater chasing after rogue eventually
catching up to her the problem is that
once She's acquired by Daniel moonstar
cater magneto Comes  in and drops a
massive vehicle On Top Of her basically
Killing her and so because of this
people Look At Him with slanted Eyes
they basically Look At Him now and say
is magneto really on our side and That's
the crazy thing about this is the way
This  is written magneto is kind of to be
like the savior of mutant Kind right The
savior of was left of the mutant
population but because of his actions
here people are Beginning to Look At Him
as left less Of A savior and more of
like a dictator or  something along those
Lines now Of course We also have Legion
and we have you know his psychic guy
showing up here and you know kind of
Trying to figure out What's Going On but
then once everything's cleared leen goes
back toa mtag now This is extremely
important because  more mtag just kind of
there her and Legion are Pretty close
although we don't really know why but
What more What more mcard IS doing is
basically Crying Over this notion that
everything is going to come crashing
down that everything is going to come
apart and  that There's nothing She can
do to stop it now Of course Legion says
I'm not going to let that happen now the
cool thing about this is it seems like
Marvel's Trying to throw us onto a
different trail right but the most
logical Line to follow  Here is that you
know with magneto basically Turning
everyone against him it seems like
magneto is going to bring the safety of
fortress x crashing down and it's going
to result in like the slaughter of all
these mutants right I mean That's like
the worst case scenario here  that
there's no more force Walls there's no
more fortress x Comes In Here they take
What's left of the mutant population
they ship them off to alcatraz they're
All executed or they lose their powers
by way of a cure or whatever the case
May Be but  then We pick up with magneto
himself and magneto of course begins
descending down into the bowels of
fortress x but the further down he goes
the further away he gets from the
communication of x itself Of course
Again this enigmatic entity that
communicates with everyone and the
reason  Why He does that At least What
We're told is that He's Doing It
intentionally He's Doing It so that He
can get to a location Where No one can
hear what it is He's saying and the
reason Why Is because He's going to
speak with rogue  and with gambit now Of
course this basically changes Everything
because What We find out Here is that
the Death of rogue she being branded as
a traitor was all a ruse that magneto
himself had sent Kitty Pride outside of
fortress x out beyond the wall because
she was  the Only One That could Face
through it to see What was on the other
side only for her to come back with
blank pictures so the question is like
What In the heck is going on well When
rogue basically figured out What was
going on magneto had to  find a way to
turn her into an Enemy to make her
disappear and then find a way to work
alongside her find a way to get the
information that she had going on in
order to try to understand What's
Happening so no one would ask questions
because remember  If everyone thinks
rogue is dead no one's going to be
looking for and so because of this What
magneto says is that he built fortress x
with his very hands using his own powers
you know using his powers of magnetism
So on and so forth he knows every  inch
of this entire facility but he says that
in the middle of this facility is a room
that He doesn't know anything about that
He's Never Seen that room Before He
doesn't know why it's there He doesn't
even know What's inside of  it and So
What He says is You're all's job is to
go into that room to figure out What's
there and understand Why it even
inhabits everything in addition to this We
basically have magneto going to Kitty
Pride freeing her of her own of her own
prison and then Taking her to meet
professor Charles xavier now This is
actually really cool because it seems
like magneto is just kind of pulling out
all the stops at this Point He's like
There are questions that need to be
answered here and I'm tired of  beating
around the Bush and he basically frees
Charles xavier from his captivity and
allows Charles xavier to kind of emerge
Again because He's No longer being
sedated and then kind of m mutters a
little bit about How they tried to fix
things they tried to make things right
but Uh ultimately passes out From The
Strain of everything that he had done
of everything that he had gotten into
now finally We pick up with rogue and we
pick up with gambit once they find
access to this room in the Center of
fortress X and What  happens is rogue
actually grabs this box now to coincide
with the event of rogue grabbing this
box is the arrival of Daniel moonstar
and her cater and they basically Corner
magneto alongside Kitty Pride with
magneto Holding The Body of xavier and
as this takes place it's this really
really cool situation Where it's like
rogue saw the contents of this box Which
basically kind of Falls to the ground at
the same time that magneto talks to
Daniel moonstar in her cater and says
look guys you have to acknowledge
There's questions here that people need
answers to  but no one seems to know what
the answers are to these questions They
Don't even know what in the world is
going on We basically kind of accept
What's Going On as An absolute Truth but
we we have no idea What's Taking place
and so because  of this you know where
where magneto tries to reason with
Daniel moonstar and Where He's actually
making a little bit of progress We
suddenly have the aral of Legion as well
as p and of course shows up here and is
like magneto's relieved of his command
magneto is  No longer in control and
That's kind of the crazy thing because
She's like fortress x is now under the
jurisdiction of the force Warriors the
ones that keep truly fortress x Safe and
so because of this What happens is We
find out that inside this box that rogue
was in Possession of Is The universe
itself The universe is inside this box
and so it's like What In the hell is
going on in this story and it's
Absolutely insane This is one of the
reasons why i l it so much cuz it's like
this Who Done it  Mystery this It's
almost like your Alice and You're just
tumbling down the Rabbit hole and it's
like I have no idea What's Happening
Right now I have no idea What's Taking
place well finally We pick up with
cannon Ball with cyclops you know We
pick up  with all these these guys Who
are basically like the Front Line so
just to say they're the ones that
directly Fight against the various Uh
you know Human forces that try to invade
fortress x every single day the
difference Here is that They always
showed up  at the same time like these
forces always shown up at the same time
every day but they haven't shown up
today and no one knows why and cyclops
basically says look guys I have the dog
tags of a person that died Yesterday but
i also have  those same dog tags of a
person that died 3 days ago I want to
know why I've killed the same person
twice you know and Then He tells
everybody else look if you have
questions here that you want answers to
if you have questions that you  you know
that you don't understand What's Going
On And you want to know What's Happening
follow me and Let's see if we can't get
answers to this and so it's basically
kind of everybody realizing that
Something's not quite right It's
everybody realizing that things  don't
seem to be What they're actually
supposed to and so what happens is that
in the middle of all this pandemic in
the middle of all this Chaos you know
with Daniel moonstar and she cater going
against you know magneto and so on and
so forth xavier finally coming to Legion
begins to Panic a bit and this is When
he says you know look She told me It
would be this way She told me that this
was going to happen She warned Me That
xavier Return each of us against each
other  This is When xavier says tell them
The Truth David like tell them whose
tune We're all dancing to and so
switching Back To more MC It looks like
more mcer did something to make things
the way They are we don't know what it
was  that she did But when you're talking
about Being Like The foremost mutant
genetic it kind of makes Sense right
Like You would know how mutant powers
work Better Than anybody I mean She's
had her you know lengthy history But you
got to remember like more mger  dealing
with proteus proteus was a character Who
could work reality on a local level I
mean he couldn't warp reality on a
Universal scale he wasn't like Franklin
richards Matthew M or mad Jim jaspers
but he could warp reality within a
localized Space but  She knows how powers
like that work would it really be that
hard for her to synthesize them for her
to synthesize the and be able to use
them not only that This is when we also
Find out thata mctaggart is x She is the
disembodied voice that everybody's  been
heard and this is kind of the crazy
situation because it's like How in the
heck does this work how in the heck does
this all come out Again it's just kind
of this continued tumbling this
continued weird sort of situation and so
what happens is once you  know cyclops
and his group Show Up To Where Charles
xavier is at you know once you have all
these forces that are kind of gathered
in one place What we do is We basically
pick up with Charles xavier telling
everybody I know What's truly Going On
here and  I Will Show all of you what it
is That's happening and this is when we
learn The Truth of the situation We pick
up with The mutant Island of utopia
about 7 Days Before All this happened
now a sidetrack for a second within
Marvel comics for those of  you guys Who do
n't know utopia was An Island that the
x-men took residence on following Tony
Stark being ousted as director of SHIELD
and norman osborne Taking his place
because norman osborn wanted to get rid
of virtually everybody that could
Challenge his control he  kind of went
After The x-men but the x-men just took
off before any of that happened it just
basically went to alcatraz Island That's
Where they Where they hung out it they
built their own fortress outside of the
Continental United States and outside of
norman osborne direct control basically
having utopia as their own separate
island off the Coast of alcatraz I Guess I
Guess it wasn't really alcatraz itself
but off the Coast of alcatraz but the
fact remains that we pick up with
charles xavier and we pick up with  a guy
named Dr nemesis working on David holler
Legion now the basis behind this project
as being worked on by both Dr nemesis
and Charles xavier is to basically cure
Legion of his personalities now Dr
nemesis guy is a guy that we've never
talked about before  but He's not really
like a mutant geneticist so much as He's
a mutant with with like a like a super
intelligence It's kind of his mutant
power but the idea Here is that David
holler has always suffered from like
multiple personality disorder That's the
basis behind it Legion  is a mutant that
has thousands of personalities each
personality has its own power set That's
Why a lot of people say when it comes
down to it mutants that have singular
personalities like Matthew m Franklin
richards are wildly powerful mutants
like Legion that have multiple
personalities Are far  beyond that
because its powers Range everywhere from
telekinesis to reality warping on a
Universal and multiversal scale and so
it's insane the kind of abilities that
he possesses but with Dr nemesis being
here working alongside xavier the goal
is basically to go through and imprison
and eliminate each  of these
personalities allowing the true David
holler to come out the issue is that
When Charles xavier delves into the mind
of David holler he basically finds this
sort of personality antibody Which is to
say it's this personality that
manifested in order to like basically
defend or protect  all the other
personalities in the mind of Uh of
Legion in order to keep them from being
destroyed and compared to the arrival of
Charles xavier this personality takes It
as An affront like you've been Trying to
destroy us We're not going to let  you do
that instead We're going to create a
world where we don't have to Worry About
You Being a threat and That's
essentially What happened here David
holler Legion basically warped reality
in a localized Space and set it up so
that in a Sense  utopia doesn't exist
anymore instead There's Only fortress
the Marvel Universe for quite some time
not only that This is when we also
realize that where you know these guys
in fortress x have been fighting for 3
years In reality only Seven Days have
passed and so everything that they've
come to believe is not  true the idea
that the Fantastic 4 turned against the
mutant population the idea that Captain
America Tony Stark the incredible hul
spider-man that they all fought on
behalf of humanity against the mutant
population none of that ever happened
instead It Was just this entire reality
warping  scenario Where David holler not
only changed localized Space or rel
Legion not only changed localized Space
he changed everyone's memories so none
of them Know The Truth About What It Is
That's going on in addition to this more
mtag as She exists Here is not actually
more mtag  instead This is the
personality of Legion that did all this
reality warping in the first place and
That's The inherent Power of Legion
That's That's What makes him so
Dangerous David holler himself feels
powerless in the face of all these
personalities now Of course What this
was designed  to do was basically set the
stage For What was called lost legions
in the Sense that once the story
basically wraps up That legions
different personalities actually Escape
out into the real world and manifest
themselves as physical beings and so
He's basically fighting all these
different personalities and  they all
have a Wide array of different powers
the story's bers but It's really really
cool at the same time It's really really
fun but because of the fact personality
is going into Panic Mode under the idea
that everything that that That is work
to build is going  to come crashing down
in response to this it basically just
initiates this massive Attack by all
these Human forces and the idea Here is
to basically Engineer a situation to
Where all the other people that are
there all the other mutants that could
possibly Rise Up against this
personality are All distracted Because
remember They Don't Know If what they
saw through char xavier is real or false
they're still clinging on to the idea
that everything that they've seen is
real but the goal of more mard of this
morag person  is to use that to their
advantage and then wipe Everything clean
sanitize the entire reality as It's been
created and replace it with a new and a
better One constantly learning as things
go on now Of course Charles xavier
speaks directly to Legion and says he
Look you  have to find a way to rectify
this you have to find a way to fix this
You Can't let things continue as They
are It's basically him telling Legion
you have to sease control of this
personality you have to make it your own
thing and So  this is what happens like
Legion actually goes after this more
mger personality and more mcer begins
freaking out saying Hey look like We
tried to make things Perfect we make get
better next time we'll Fix it you know
we'll solve all this But in  response
Legion basically destroys that aspect of
his personality he basically wipes it
from existence goes out to the
Battlefield and destroys Everything
That's out there destroys you know all
these different Enemy ships because
remember they're not actually there
they're all just whatever It is  at leion
wants them to be and so If he wills them
out of existence then they're gone This
is the other half of this situation that
Where Legion had basically warped
reality to a degree changed what it
seems like he'd actually done is grabbed
utopia and removed it from the Universe
so it creates this really really weird kind
of situation but ultimately he ends
up setting Everything Back To normal he
basically allows things to go back to
the way they were before Where utopia is
restored Charles xavier back and the
cool  thing about this is that it allows
Marvel to kind of do a Soft Reboot with
the Uh new mut and x-men Legacy Line in
the Sense that characters that it
previously died were now brought back
because There were some characters in
the story that were Dead  before the
events of Age of x that were alive in
Age of x it was basically you know
Legion just kind of recreating them and
bringing them Back To Life and That's
essentially What happened here once
everything's returned to normal they came
with it they came with the  the normal
Universe and so at this Point What the
story does is Again you know it kind of
it kind of wraps up here but What the
story does is it goes into An event
called Age of X aftermath and then that
begins to go into Lost legions  Which
kind of just follows Legion you know as
He's going to try to round up these
different personalities as He's Trying
to catch these different aspects of
himself but This is a story that I
always thought was kind of cool Because
I like the idea that it just  sort of
picked up in the middle of Everything
and you're like What the heck is going
on but it was one of these really really
interesting Stories from Marvel comics
but There's also this whole thing I want
to say that Age of x Universe number one
and number two which actually exps
everything that happened leading up to
this Point like I think There's also Ag
of x Alpha which explains Uh jean gry
Killing 600,000 people it explains pchs
being Used as a weapon explains Like The
Avengers And spider-man you all those
guys going after the mutant population
Why It is they went after the mutant
population all that kind of cool stuff
it creates a really interesting
situation But if you guys are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob Core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and Yeah I
catch you all later
peace
[music]
C